this is Keystone Motel guess who else is
fucked in the head both of them yes well
it turns out when you have a split
personality
I literally yeah so continuing from the
last episode which I like uh you know
pearl fuel because we're actually
watching them in order yeah that Amazon
still is now putting them in order I
have to go on the phone I don't know I
was responsible for that but you suck
yeah like it is way out of order um but
yep I look up the actual list and
everything obviously um so garden is
still very angry at Pearl even though
Pearl's trying to work hard and be
forgiving and stuff uh and then the
father convinces are going on a road
trip and garnet wants to come with get
away from everything gets really angry
with herself quite literally splits
apart basically turns into sideways
where you're on a road trip of people
who should not be together
yes and Ruby and Sapphire are seen again
and we learned I guess yeah we learn
more about it when you figure out one
they literally run hot and cold uh one
is you know fire and everything the
other is uh can freeze stuff and one is
very angry and one is very calm all cold
yes uh I like that they're like it was
like a metaphor for their personnel is
like one runs hot one runs cold no I
thought that was very clever and Stephen
thinks maybe might be his fault and they
realize well they don't think the
biggest thing I found out is they don't
think on the United Front all the time
like it kind of it always seems to be
for the most part presented kind of like
that but this is the first time I'm like
okay she's messed up too like these two
it's like inside out if these two
frickin argue with each other all of a
sudden it's like yeah and what and I
again all of them are flawed in some
ways I mean that once justice yeah but
we garner we haven't seen that much of
it like I feel like this is the first
time I'm like okay this is a real garnet
meltdown well and I think that's why you
know what was revealed that she was a
fusion the whole time like I really want
to know more about them cuz it's like
you know she is so put together and she
is so well balanced it's like but you
know it's because these two people are
together and it's like you
no that can't last you know you have to
see especially with such two extreme
personalities well it makes her whole
personality now like seeing these to
operate I'm like well there it is like
the sort of ass-kicking side measured
with the sort of cold detached logical
side and you get that sort of balance no
I completely for the most part unless
this happens but they come together and
they they fused once again get a very
friendly with each other on a sales kind
of like when they get to like the neck
kissing and stuff that's kinda like wow
we're getting a little uh well pg-13
here for a kiss Oh um but um fuckin PG
what are you talking about look at you
don't see that you don't see a couple
like on a kitchen why kissing each
other's neck I mean thinking kiss on the
lips and may the heads out of anyone
there like kissing each other's necks
and stuff okay so they're getting
playful with their sexuality just a
touch but helping it in a kid show you
don't usually see that kind of hi I
don't know I feel like I've seen plenty
of Disney movies or the main characters
kiss no no you met each other no no that
one yes and you know obviously it's
fairy tales and stuff but like I don't
know there's something about like you
know you see kissing a list all the time
it's like when you're getting like into
like the neck and the chest and stuff
like that just like wow something about
that seems like just a little more
sexualized at what I'm used Atlee to I'm
used to seeing a kitchen I'm not saying
it's bad but there it is usually see no
no I'm not saying it's bad I'm saying I
don't usually don't know like they're
actually really in love and act kind of
like a married couple getting frisky
with each other not oh I just met this
character five minutes ago yes where's
your marry well and will you get angry
they really seem like it where they
separate a one is like fuming and
screaming the others just very you know
trying to stay in control know
everything this is since you're bringing
that then this is what fucking pisses me
off okay I'm about the way American
society is set up it's like we have to
freak out about that two characters in
love acting kind of like a married
couple and getting a little frisky with
each other and being friendly and
flirting and showing that they're in
love
that's too much for generally if it's
two girls holy shit but you know
meanwhile the Disney movies where it's
just like hey we just met or I kiss you
and you wake up you mine now bitch
like it just that's fine like it I'm not
talking about you know these others it
what even frozen it's just like you
can't marry a guy you just met she still
does with with the knowledge it is a
Miriam she don't think nothing married
at the other big shoes what you knew oh
yeah uh maybe should heart it may be
showmanship that can blossom maybe maybe
it shows you that I kind of forgot parts
of that film cuz if that fucking song
fucking song um but yeah even most your
classic Disney films up until the past
are you long yeah fine like my view so
yeah probably five is a long history of
like 50 plus years of Disney films where
you get these sort of instant romances I
yeah like that's okay but two characters
who have been in love for forever and
like are in a committed relationship
like flirting with each other stand back
oh let's go up the youth of America well
no no there's a few things to keep in
mind one is that the style of those
fills particularly the early ones is
classic fairy tale that's not a world
where that much logic sort of comes in
where something here the emotional logic
and the details and so forth they are
structured in a different way they're
fucking rocks what are you talking about
logic no no no but you know okay in Snow
White and whatever Wizard of Oz and
stuff like that they're not gonna sit
down and discuss their emotions like
they are in this show that's not the
style that's not the setup you find
unless is this even better I didn't say
it was bad I'm saying it's something
that you're not used to seeing you know
on a kids show I also don't think it's
so busy adults are just like Oh human
real human emotions our kids can't see
that shit no no I'm not saying it's bad
I'm saying I'm not you listen you're
saying it's bad that's what I'm saying
they're saying but they didn't say that
they showed it not I'm not talking about
I'm talking about the people who were
like raising holy hell against this show
cuz two chicks got all flirty with each
other
hey but I didn't I know but that's why
I'm saying it's an aside that pisses me
off in general
so subject change you hate when closed
my date idiots are saying hey idiot be
my clothes my idiot also got it okay you
brought it up cuz he's like I don't know
that was a little through them like that
was barely that was PG tops I've seen
particularly PG stuff in the 80s like
which members g13 now it reminded me
when which is also a PG film but in
Incredibles I remember there's a scene
where like the husband-wife are passing
by and like keep it keep inches her ass
and then she pinches his ass I was just
like wow like Disney cartoons have come
much further than you know what we're
used to seeing because that just seems
like something that wouldn't fly like
you know so some years ago but it still
shows affection it still shows
playfulness it still shows you know this
nice connection and I think it's the
same thing here if they were just about
to marry well they're a bunch of sex
addicts just looking to bonk like that's
something different but I'm like they're
in a loving relationship they truly love
each other ya know there's nothing that
was PG material I just saw hmm so I
agree no that's why I brought up cuz
your looks of pg-13 materials oh God
like steamy what no fur fur kid shows
this is no I watch anime hole I've seen
way worse no but this is not something
usually seeing kid shows I'm not saying
it's something that shouldn't be if
anything I I think especially the way it
was and I have seen worse with a
showgirl I've seen worse with girl on
boy I've seen worse with boy boy I've
seen worse it with girl Montana cop like
you come from anime you see shit this
was just adorable where do you spend
your nights
well obviously online um so okay so we
got that settled uh let's talk a little
bit more about science buggin um but the
uh you know III went through a similar
kind of rage we're talking on a
Wednesday I went through a very similar
raid yesterday when the editorial when
I'm talking about the fair use because I
knew this was important episode and so
many things were going wrong to prolong
this and to delay it and I you know some
of the footage I got wasn't chilling
with premiere and something I could only
use audio and then premiere was shit
that all this stuff and I just for the
first
a while like you know the months now I
just had like an explosion I was exactly
like her I was just literally like
walking bad like that :
yeah I was exact like Ruby and my wife
was exactly like sapphire she's saying
they're trying to beat you know just you
keep yourself calm just be I am
literally pacing back and forth cuz I'm
just so angry I can call the police
sirens I love and even more then she
walked around in the pool so long that
water evaporated all the water yeah I
like the way they show them again I like
the cold in the room I like her freezing
the room and stuff so I guess it like
her freezing okay I liked her freezing
the room too because she's not freezing
the room in the other scene so it's like
they're hot cold thing is a reflection
of their emotional stage so she in that
moment even though she looked calm was
just as raging yeah uh there's
definitely something going on you know
she just hails in a different way but it
still I'm glad they address hey she's
not you know the Sapphire is not
completely in control either and this
isn't totally the right I thought it was
interesting and we finally kind of know
where this is since they mentioned the
Keystone State
mm I didn't know exactly where this was
I figured East Coast somewhere but I
couldn't figure out where no I'm very
sad before it's gotta be somewhere
New York Jersey merrily in the if they
say the Keystone State it's not unless
literally the name of the state Keystone
State like they made it no it's fucking
Pennsylvania no I know it is but when he
showed though you said yeah the Keystone
say it's drawn like Pennsylvania I'll
say it'd be funny feels like in the
future or something and they like
actually gallery of the day Pennsylvania
for some reason like just renamed it
Utah State or something like that on a
mineral name I'm sure that I'm sure that
I'm sure they have a literal name we
just haven't looked it up yeah um I'm
sure someone will answer but yeah that's
all I could I never knew where this at
the first episode that was supposed to
be on the west coast but then as it kept
going I'm like now Beach City I like
this whole thing feels more like it not
Atlantic City because it's got a bunch
of casinos if I'm like it if you've got
that boardwalk II kind of like pretty
yeah vacation coastal town on the east
coast so well but yeah now to me I'm
just like okay so it's somewhere in that
I stayed area oh and the reason I
brought up the the anger thing is cuz
the way they animated her anger Ally
especially you know like her grabbing
the table and stuff like that I mean
just the little a lot of times in
cartoons when so is angry they just
punch something you know but this really
showed I just just getting off of that
frustration I'm like no they're
capturing this very well um I like
Stephens dad son someday you will learn
to appreciate all pizza that's like my
favorite lock square feet so crazy
places this one day you'll learn to
respect all keys that true that there is
still some pizza out there that sucks
well yeah there's pizza hey even I won't
say that yet to really try to piss me
off with pizza pizza is probably like my
favorite food yeah if I really a slice
of pizza up and it literally falls like
a flaccid penis then your pizzas no like
New York Pizza I can't do it I'm like
the bed I know your pizza but there's
definitely bad new you it's an
unfinished calzone and I'm like why am i
fully not having the right New York in a
good New York Pizza he only made any
good reader but you just saw few not
only good I've had New York Pizza in New
York multiple times
the only good we lived in New England
the only good New York Pizza I had
ironically was hip place we went to in
fucking Florida that was a good place it
was in Tampa it was amazing I wish I
could remember the name of that place no
I've had very offended I would tell
people now if you live in the Florida
area it's a downtown Tampa and there's
like some New York pizza place and
they're like we as actual New York water
it's fun and apparently New York water
has like mystical properties it like it
does if you can do your quantum AC gives
you force powers and also a fifth
eyeballs immediately when I wouldn't
doubt it like it's actually phenomenal
oh I'm not a big fan of st. Louis pizza
that cracker pizza uh I like that fine
okay I just that's not a racial term by
the way in excess like a cracker like
it's like so failure crackers yeah so
then it's like eating pizza those two
I'm not I'm not really huge fans of but
curate all other forms of pizza you
can't go wrong I'm with you I think you
just arrived like give out the wet
cardboard pizza I don't really
so sidetracked it again I'm sorry for
yours we're done talking about it we can
talk about pizza what else is there to
talk about we can talk about PA today
fine to talk about we winter everything
they fought they got back together
garnet said later to Pearl and that made
her happy because at least they're
speaking again now getting back to pizza
sis it is time to talk about fair use
and pizza these are the two important
issues right now we need to discuss they
are not being discussed Oh brick oven
fired this is my that it doesn't get
better than that I know like what that
goes kind of well none of it's none of
its dumb right the the new year then
it's just the same way that's me I'm
writing a not very good but see the the
smaller brick oven fired the Neapolitan
style they're only like this big so when
you cut it it falls a little but like a
New York slice is literally the size of
a Star Destroyer and it's so it's like
it's this big and so when you pick it up
it literally it's like picking up a wet
towel no no even though I guess when you
slides up and are like wow what you
gotta do is fold it I'm like then while
I order a fucking calzone cuz that's all
that is this I agree when it's like wet
cardboard that's like when it's just so
lit it's like the grease is so thick
that ever eating paper a place in
Florida run by the New Yorkers who
imported the New York water was very
very good I did not have any good New
York Pizza in New York I did not I had
some very good nigger pizza but again I
I love Chicago pizza I went to multiple
places and that's the funny thing it was
like the fuck kagu shit but I'm like no
that's somewhere in the middle I think I
like Neapolitans outbreak come and sit
paint away I was made fucking Italy
ironically like all the pizza you can
arrive here is square like there's very
handsome it adds a Midwestern yeah no I
actually do kind of miss round pizza
though the square feet is really good
too I just love pizza I'm sure looks
like lose I lose over Giordano's or even
idly I would go losing Gino's East yeah
then maybe you're getting it did you but
but what people consider like Chicago
style pizza isn't always the pie that
refers to talk I'm just telling you
everybody thinks it's the Giordano's
stuffed pizza
it's not it's more like the original
Chicago sounds more like Lou Malnati's
oh yeah it's thick but that's what one
John Stewart over a little mound on yeah
the Lou Malnati's is the one that John
Stehr was like okay - oh by the way when
he handed him silverware John Stewart's
like what am i a fucking and audience is
like I love that but here's the
interesting thing you don't have to eat
a lose pizza with silverware you can't
pick it up yeah Giordano's then no way
you got you need the silverware yeah oh
but so I'm not gonna sit here in defense
kaga Pete's is the greatest either but I
I will assist I won't no I won't defend
it as some of the better pizza and I
will defend lose as fucking amazing the
the stuff style Giordano is not as much
but it's way better than New York staff
and like in New York I still think it's
probably way better than that
cracker they serve down in st. Louis but
I'm glad we could bring this episode
about emotions running high even
literally
I have now offended two states who else
California Pizza what's that broccoli on
Pizza good job San Francisco oh god I've
got two states down who else get who
else makes pizza I'm gonna stop before
you insult Connecticut style pizza is
actually pretty good I like the white
pizza with them but it was very good I
think I've run out of pizza to hug the
Canadians to pizza yo you can get MEC
pizza in some parts of Canada it's awful
by the way okay actually we can agree
New Yorkers st. Louis Chicago California
Connecticut Italy everybody MEC pizza is
the worst I think we need to stop I just
brought everybody together